في اخبارنا الاخرى بدا مليون ونصف المليون
من موظفي لجنه الانتخابات العامه في
باكستان فرز اصوات عشرات الملايين من
المقترعين في الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي
جرت اليوم الخميس وافد مراسل الجزيره
بمقتل 48 شخصا بينهم عناصر امن واصابه
عشرات اخرين في احداث عنف وقعت الخميس
وخلال الايام الماضيه وغاب عن المشاركه في
الانتخابات رئيس الوزراء الاسبق عمران خان
بسبب قرار قضائي يمنعه من ممارسه العمل
السياسي لمده خمسه اعوام
معنا من اسلام اباد مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
الرحمن مطر اذا كيف تجري عمليه الفرس في
هذه الاجواء الامنيه
المتوتره عمليه فرز الاصوات حقيقه بدات
قبل بعض الوقت وهي مستمره ومن المتوقع ان
تستمر طيله هذه الليله هنا في باكستان
وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بمحاوله الوصول الى
نتائج مؤكده ل العديد من الدوائر
الانتخابيه نحن نتحدث عن مئات من الدوائر
الانتخابيه في عموم باكستان هذه
الانتخابات انتخابات برلمانيه عامه بمعنى
انه سيتم انتخاب اعضاء البرلمان الفيدرالي
هنا في العاصمه اسلام اباد وايضا اعضاء
البرلمانات المحليه في الاقاليم الاربعه
التي تتكون منها الدوله او الجمهوريه
الباكستانيه برلمانات اقليم البنجاب اقليم
السند اقليم بلوشستان وايضا اقليم خيبر
وبالتالي هناك الكثير من الجهود التي تبدل
في هذه الدقائق وست ستستمر طله هذه الليله
في محاوله التاكد وحصد كل الاصوات التي
ساهمت في الانتخابات اليوم الوضع الامني
حقيقه كان بالفعل له دور ما فيما يتعلق
بالعمليه الانتخابيه لا سيما واننا اليوم
سجلنا على الاقل وقوع اربع حوادث امنيه
راح ضحيتها عره اشخاص فيما انه خلال
الايام القليله الماضي ايضا قتل اكثر من
من تقريبا من 40 شخصا خلال حوادث مشابهه
الوضع الامني كان له دور لكن الانتقاد
السياسي للحكومه المؤقته هنا في باكستان
كان قويا خلال هذا اليوم لا سما بسبب
انقطاع الاتصال وانقطاع خدمه الانترنت منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى ومنذ فتح صناديق
الاقتراع صباح اليوم بد مدير مكتب الجزيره
عبد الرحمن مطر شكرا جزيلا لك